(stapler clicks)
(yelling)
- I was the only one who tucked.
- There was, again, no reason for that.
- I still don't really
understand what tucking is.
- It's when you shove your
balls up into your body.
- Inside of your...
- [All] Hi, we're the Try Guys!
- And welcome to our special
two year anniversary video.
(fun rock music)
(cheering)
- [Ned] For the past two years, we've been
making videos together and
becoming close friends.
- So today, we're gonna re-watch
several of our very first videos.
(grunts)
(yelling)
- Oh my.
- To see what shaped us into
becoming who we are today.
Where are my pants?
- Do we still order that pizza?
(everyone laughs)
(fun electronic music)
- Gonna get it.
We gonna get it.
The first video that I
chose we should watch
is actually our Kim
Kardashian Butt Photo video.
Does this make me look
more like a sexy librarian?
I edited this footage and I can say,
glimpses of everyone's dick were put
into BuzzFeed's permanent backup system.
- This started a trend of Eugene
way out-dressing us in every shoot.
- [Keith] And drinking in every shoot.
- Not a trend, that's how
I dress at the office.
- For the first couple of videos, we tried
really hard to get other people involved.
- We're basically the Try Guys
'cause we're the grossest
people at BuzzFeed.
- [Ned] Oh yeah.
(groaning)
- I think what's interesting, though,
is that the four of us are not
necessarily your traditional,
like, super hyper-masculine,
confident dudes.
And to have to put our
butts on the internet,
that was a huge step for all of us.
- Once you go butt, you can't go back.
(electronic music)
- My favorite Eugene moment, by far, is in
our K-drama episode
when Eugene just, like,
brutally attacked Ned with his mouth.
- Hey!
(muffled laughing)
I won.
(laughs)
- What did you win?
- Seducing you.
(laughs)
- What's next?
- This is one of my all-time favorites.
The Try Guys Try Drag For The First Time.
It was kind of, like,
our first time really
immersing ourselves into another culture.
- Ah, it's like a condom for my head.
- Not only transforming
physically, but having to
perform and act out something
over a course of a day.
(stapler clicks)
(yells)
- Inside of your body?
- It's like if you jump in a cold pool
and your balls kind of retreat.
- I just don't, maybe
my balls are too big.
- There's cavities there, that's
where they descended from.
- Because of this video,
if we ever encounter
drag queens, they know
us by our drag personas.
- Ginger Vitis.
- My name's Ginger Vitis.
I'm so sweet, I'm gonna give you a cavity.
But don't worry, I'll fill it.
- This was the day before Thanksgiving,
and all during Thanksgiving dinner,
my grandma just asked me
relentlessly about drag culture.
- Yay!
- I'm like, "Grandma, I
did this for one day."
"But what do you wanna know?"
(cheering)
- Ned looked like every
trashy Hollywood starlet
that was close to crashing and burning.
- I think I would go
to the bar, I would try
and pickup Eugene, and I'd
end up going home with Ned.
- [Ned] Hell yeah.
- [Keith] I'm going after Ned.
- And I would let everyone (loud beep) me.
(laughs)
- I didn't think that
was gonna be dumb enough!
(electronic music)
Gosh, there's so many dumb Ned moments
to choose from, you know?
(laughs)
(yells)
Obviously like, any fan can
make a 30 minute montage
of anytime Ned has mentioned his wife.
- My wife, my wife, my wife, my wife,
my wife, my wife, my wife.
It's my wife!
I can't wait to have a baby.
- Oh, gross.
- Daddy likey.
I love this next video so much.
It's called The Try Guys
Test The Legal Alcohol Limit
and it's the first time that we applied
scientific principles to something
you don't normally get
too scientific about.
AKA, partyin'.
- Drankin'.
- It's the morning after.
I feel like fucking death.
It's really funny seeing
the people that we were able
to convince to come to my house
to get drunk on a Tuesday?
- Tuesday night.
(laughs)
- We're at work.
I was very intimidated
dancing with this girl.
- [All] Yeah.
- She was a very good dancer,
and she wasn't my wife.
♫ I don't know what to do with my hands
- Okay, honestly, Keith
and I, we were being
very responsible during this video.
Zack and Ned became little kids.
- [Ned] Nut tap.
(laughs)
- Guys, guys, guys.
- What better way to have fun
than by hitting all your
friends in the dick?
(laughs)
- You guys are not even legally drunk?
- Everyone's responsible.
- I think it's awesome
that we get to educate
people as well as entertainment.
And we've continued that
trend with videos like
Try Guys Get Prostate Exams,
Try Guys Test Their Sperm Count.
- Bottom line, we're
tryna make science cool.
- To me, this has proven people get drunk.
- What?
(electronic music)
My favorite Keith moment
is probably the time
when he made me almost pee
myself from laughing so hard.
Try Guys Try Edible Lingerie.
(groaning)
(laughs)
Where he got his lingerie
stuck in his mouth.
- Oh, they're, like, stuck to my teeth.
Oh God, they're turning my hands red!
- [Zack] And then it
got caught in his butt.
- [Ned] It got caught in his butt.
- My pants!
- And he's just like (yells)
- No!
(crying)
What's it on, what are they holding on to?
What's wrong with me?
Pizza's here!
(everyone cheering)
So now that we got pizza, what's next?
- So, this is the Try
Guys Try UFC Fighting.
Our necks were sore for, straight up,
like two weeks after this.
Let's watch Eugene get tossed!
(body smacks mat)
- [All] Oh!
(everyone groaning)
- Look at that big boner I had.
- That was not a boner, it was a cup.
Everyone thinks Eugene has a boner
in the beginning of
this video, it's a cup.
- Boner.
(grunting)
Zack, were you actually
afraid of getting hit?
- Yes!
- Also, he showed the example of how to do
the Achilles hold so many times
that he bruised my Achilles.
(yelling)
My brain!
- I love athletic competitions, mm.
- Anytime we do a competition video,
these two immediately forget
that we're filming a video
and it becomes all about
beating each other.
- But that also makes for a great video.
(yelling)
- [Keith] Me and Zack
don't fight, we just hug.
- I do not endorse this at all.
- So look, did Eugene
beat me in this fight?
- [Eugene] Barely.
- Technically, sure, yes.
- [Eugene] I didn't want to hurt you.
(everyone laughing)
- Didn't wanna hurt you, you said,
as you punch him in the back of the head?
- I'mma be honest, I didn't have
a hernia before the Try Guys.
- [Ned] It's really surprising that I
haven't gotten injured
in a Try Guys video.
- [Keith] Right?
- Well, you're already so
injured before we shoot the
Try Guys videos, there's no
point in getting more injured.
(laughs)
- [Cameraman] Did you kiss your cast?
- Yeah.
- [Cameraman] What is that?
(electronic music)
So, my favorite Zack moment is when he
innocently discovers his
face is the clitoris.
- [Cameraman] Where's the clitoris?
- Am I the...
- Is my face the clitoris?
- Am I the clitoris?
Oh my God, I'm the clitoris!
There's a world of people
who know me exclusively as
the clit guy and if, for
nothing else, thank you, world.
I've made my mark.
What a toasty vagina.
- Did you use that whiskey?
- No.
- What are you, where did that come from?
Have you been...
- [Ned] It's 11 AM.
- [Zack] Have you been sitting
on that this whole time?
Cheers.
- Cheers.
- To two years.
- Wait, if we're toasting, then
pour me some whiskey, Jesus.
- You know what drinking
whiskey makes me think of?
Pregnancy.
(laughs)
That's why we should go
watch the motherhood series.
- [Keith] So, this is the video where
we let people electrocute our bellies.
(screams)
- This legitimately terrified me.
- Well, this isn't a
skill, this is just pain.
- The faces that Keith makes.
You have such mouth flexibility.
- [Eugene] Keith has the largest
mouth I've ever seen on a human.
- It could swallow worlds.
- Let's all make a Keith face.
(groans)
- So much of this video is screaming.
Oh, that hurts a lot!
(laughing in pain)
- Watching your friends
get hurt is so delightful.
- Like, this was just muscle contractions
but like, a baby can rip you apart.
- Oh my God, it's even worse now.
Oh, this is the worst.
- What we're tryin' to say
is, men are giant pussies.
- Us especially so.
- [Keith] Yep, oh yep.
- You got, you good with the pizza?
- I'm just gettin' rid of that pizza.
I think we should watch the
first video we ever made.
- Yes.
- Like, it's been two years.
September 12th of 20...
- 2014.
- 2014 was when they first came out.
- Let's see where it all began.
- Yeah.
- Da, da, da, da, da, da.
- What I remember about
this is that we were
worried about people
seeing us in underwear.
(laughs)
Oh, how far we've come.
Ooh!
Okay.
- Yeah!
Make my butt look good!
- I remember that their underwear is
so much cozier than our underwear is.
- [Zack] Smooth.
- It's so cozy.
- This is also when we weren't known
by a first name basis to the audience.
So I was always the Asian One.
- [Keith] Tall Guy With Glasses.
- Short Guy With Glasses.
- Tiny Nerd.
(laughs)
Nobody knows.
Just a white guy.
- It's funny, I don't love this video,
but I'm so appreciative for it because it
kinda started us on this journey, right?
Like, I look at the
last two years, how much
I've grown as a person,
how much we've grown
as friends, and how much
I've grown as a video-maker.
And this is really where it all started.
- I think as someone
who's never had brothers,
this is the closest I've
had to having brothers.
- In two years, we've swam
with sharks, we've fought
each other, we've been
naked for an entire day
in the hot sun, we have
vomited into the ocean.
- Well, you vomited in it.
- One of us.
- Well, one of us.
- One of us did.
- Okay, we did it together.
(laughs)
- The only reason that's possible is
'cause people keep watchin' it, so thanks.
- Thank you.
- Thanks, guys.
- Yeah, it's really because
of the audience, right?
- It is, always is.
- That's really what it is.
- But here's a money shot.
- Oh!
(classy guitar music)
- I promise you, if we
get to 200 episodes,
we'll (loud beep) each other.
(everyone laughs loudly)
That's what you want, that's the second
most requested video in the comments.
(rock music)
- Do you guys ever stop
and think about how
many millions of people
have seen your butt?